[Music]
what is this worm seen in the second
episode of rings of power so yeah the
series isn't as good as they have
promoted it to be but that's what you
get from forcing something not really
desired by the public but then again
there is one or two things that were
interesting in the series
so i've convinced myself that this is
just a billion dollar fan fiction and
that made it more tolerable in a way but
one thing that got me excited was the
giant kaiju sized sea monster called the
worm so we will dissect a little bit
into it and discuss what it is and
whether it is canon or just another
piece of fan fiction so let's get to it
let's start with the scene of the sea
monster so in the second episode when
galadriel was swimming back to middle
earth from valinor which was completely
ridiculous since the sundering sea is
thousands of miles across
like the length of the atlantic ocean in
the lease anyway she was rescued by a
group of survivors who themselves were
stranded in the ocean after their ship
was attacked by a seabees
they helped her up and told her about
the sea worm then out of nowhere the
creature comes back to finish killing
the remaining survivors
so let's look at its appearance the
design of the monster resembles an
aquatic reptile from the mesozoic era it
has a body similar to a giant
mossosaurus with two large fins in the
front and a large tail with bicon cave
type of flipper fins its head was
monstrous looking it had a horn on the
nose that gives off a pacific rim kaiju
kind of vibe as it does look similar to
knifehead from that franchise its back
is lined with several sail fins that are
segmented from each other the eyes are
situated on the top which means that it
has predatorial vision which allows it
to stalk and attack prey that swim close
to the surface of the ocean
it also has several giant dust-like
teeth that protrude out of the mouth so
it was pretty good looking
let's estimate the size this creature
was absolutely gigantic and it is maybe
one of the biggest creatures in that
universe of middle earth aside from the
weir worms the dragons and the stone
giants the horn itself seems to be
around eight to ten feet long which
means its head is going to measure
around twice that size so we have an
estimate of a head size that is 16 to 20
feet long
then if we infer that its body design is
proportionate to or similar to a
mososaurus or other large sea reptiles
of the past and we have a head to body
ratio of one is to five therefore the
creature would be 80 to 100 feet long
not surprising as this estimate seems to
conform with how it looks in the show so
let's take a look at its habitat the
creature is an ocean dwelling monster
and hunts in the open seas most notably
in the sundering seas as well as other
parts of the vast oceans of middle earth
as we can see from the maps in the
series
these waters lay west of middle-earth
and elves must cross them in order to
reach the undying lands
as seen in the episode the sea worm had
quite a lot of javelins and spears stuck
on its body which would tell us that it
frequently has contact or conflicts with
humans and other sea going races maybe
even else and has formed quite an
antagonistic attitude towards them
so what if it is evil or just
misunderstood we can't clearly state
whether this creature is under the
influence of sauron since there is no
literature behind it but we can clearly
guess that it is a gigantic creature
wandering the oceans of middle earth and
might just be an apex predator that
seeks out prey
but at the same time in the attack scene
we saw a lot of spears and javelins
stuck to its body probably shot or
thrown at it by fishermen hunting for
big game kind of like moby dick so maybe
it has developed a dislike or extreme
enmity and hatred towards people and
ships because of it but only the future
episodes will tell
so are there such things in the books
written by tolkien
well sea serpents are essentially the
aquatic equivalent of dragons in most
fantasy settings including middle-earth
they may easily capsize ships due to
their size and strength
the watcher in the water from the
fellowship of the ring is the only
creature like it an aquatic creature
to be discussed by token as no
particular sea serpents have ever been
addressed but there are worms that are
cannon to the franchise the hobbits have
a story about gigantic worms that are
said to dwell in the last desert and
also in the movie hobbit a battle of the
five armies there were a couple of
wereworms that were seen tunneling and
making way for orcs so even though the
sea worm was never a part of tolkien's
middle earth its appearance does give a
little bit of salt to a bland dish that
is the rings of power
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take a fam